heute stellen wir euch mal deutsche
interaktionen von interaktionen sind
sogenannte ausrufe wörter so was wie ach
und man benutzt sie besonders häufig in
der gesprochenen sprache und oft
transportieren diese interaktionen
emotionen manchmal auch bewertungen oder
auch auf forderungen an andere menschen
heute zeigen wir euch mal einige
interaktionen die ihr besonders häufig
hier auf der straße in deutschland hören
werdet los geht's our rogues zu genug
sagt man immer dann wenn einem etwas
wehtut und die kurze version von auer
die man auch häufig hört ist und diese
wörter werden zwar besonders häufig bei
kindern benutzt aber auch als
erwachsener kann man durchaus auer und
auch benutzen und das zweite wort was
ihr gehört habt in der szene ist krupps
kennt ihr vielleicht weil es das auch im
englischen gibt und es dort eigentlich
genauso klingt und auch im deutschen
sagt man immer dann wenn etwas aus
versehen passiert übrigens gar nicht ich
habe mir eine neue gitarre gekauft 8
ich dachte du hättest gar kein geld mehr
hat diesen monat ja und deshalb habe ich
das geld von unserem gemeinsamen konto
ach drückt häufig eine überraschung aus
wenn einen etwas total überrascht dann
kann man zum beispiel zu einer anderen
person sagen ach und dieses auch wird
auch ganz oft mit anderen wörtern
kombiniert vielleicht habt ihr schon mal
gehört achso oder ach herrje
und wir haben über dieses wort sogar
schon mal ein ganzes video gemacht und
auch leute auf der straße befragt wie
das wie sie das benutzen und dieses
video findet ihr hier verlinkt das
zweite wort was ihr in der szene gehört
habt ist so kann man auch benutzen wenn
einen etwas überrascht aber man benutzt
es vor allem dann wenn irgendwas negativ
ist in dieser überraschung oder man
drückt damit aus dass einem das nicht
gefällt was ist das hier einfach
eigentlich der macht ihr die straße
sauber
[Musik]
ein anderes wort was sehr ähnlich klingt
aber hat was ganz anderes bedeutet ist
aha aha sagt man immer dann wenn man
etwas gerade versteht oder wenn man
etwas realisiert wenn man vielleicht zum
ersten mal was verstanden hat dann sagt
aha oder wenn einem jemand etwas erzählt
hat und dann hat man plötzlich den
ganzen kontext verstanden sagt man
aha ja klar und dieses wort hört man
sehr oft auf der straße in deutschland
was hast du könig es probieren alter ein
wort was man vor allem sehr häufig in
der jugendsprache hört ist der ausdruck
alter alter heißt ganz wörtlich ein
alter mensch eigentlich und dieses wort
ist mittlerweile aber ein ausdruck für
ganz vieles man kann sagen alter wenn
man sagen möchte ist das krass wenn man
überrascht ist man kann aber auch sagen
alter wenn einem etwas nicht gefällt und
man zeigt damit das gefällt mir nicht
auch in österreich ist dieser begriff
sehr populär und dort heißt es aber ein
bisschen anders man sagt dort also
eigentlich alter aber mit der
österreichischen aussprache und es wird
auch im dialekt geschrieben
jetzt habe ich noch einen kleinen tipp
für alle von euch die die deutsche
aussprache trainieren möchten ihr könnt
mal unsere app ceiling ausprobieren
dort werdet ihr nämlich aufgefordert
jeden satz den er hört noch einmal
aufzunehmen und selbst zu wiederholen
dadurch trainiert ihr eure aussprache in
einer sicheren umgebung ohne euch nervös
füllen zu müssen und werden schritt für
schritt besser ceiling findet ihr im
google place tor und im app store zum
download
wenn ihr noch mal probieren vorjahr nur
ein anderes wort was man richtig richtig
häufig auf der straße hört in
deutschland ist bora bora ist so etwas
wie die deutsche version von wow
aber dieses englische wort wir benutzt
man mittlerweile in deutschland auch und
eigentlich auch mit der gleichen
bedeutung also ihr könnt euch merken
man kann wohl sagen wenn man beeindruckt
ist man kann aber auch sagen und bohrt
funktioniert positiv man kann positiv
beeindruckt seien zum beispiel ja ich
hab ne tolle neue gitarre und ich komme
in sein zimmer und sage boah krasse
guitar jarisch oder es kann auch sein
dass irgendetwas negatives passiert zb
janisch lässt mich zwei stunden warten
und dann sage ich boah janosch hier ist
den kaffee bitte sie
was ist los was ist denn da drin
sojamilch mit zucker sowie du wolltest
jetzt das mag ich nicht
im deutschen gibt es gleich mehrere
wörter um auszudrücken dass man etwas
eklig findet oder sogar angst vor etwas
hat man kann zum beispiel sagen wenn man
etwas nicht mag man kann auch sagen geht
und die kurzform von edith ist einfach
je ich würde sagen ja nüscht eine spinne
an der decke und dann kommt ja nciht und
hilft mir ein ganz populäres deutsches
wort ist auch ja ja sagt man immer dann
eigentlich wenn man resignation
ausdrückt also wenn etwas passiert ist
und man kann das nicht mehr ändern dann
sagt ja dann haben wir den bus halt
verpasst manchmal kann es auch bedeuten
oder manchmal kann es diesen unterton
haben dass man das vielleicht schon hat
kommen sehen also vielleicht habe ich ja
nicht gesagt sie ja du musst du auch die
jacke mitnehmen es regnet gleich und
dann steht ja nicht im regen und dann
sage ich ja habe ich noch gesagt
hey du hast doch ein nichts mehr drin
eins meiner lieblingswörter ist dieses
hält kann man immer dann sagen wenn man
etwas nicht versteht oder etwas nicht
weiß oder eine frage hat und es ist aber
sehr umgangssprachlich eine formelle
version davon wäre vielleicht wie bitte
also wenn ihr am telefon seit und etwas
nicht versteht dann sagt ihr
wie bitte oder entschuldigungen können
sie das noch mal wiederholen
aber wenn ihr unter freunden spricht
dann könnt ihr sagen hey was meinst du
damit
wenn euch dieses video gefallen hat dann
schreibt uns mal einen kommentar hier
unten hin und sagt uns bescheid denn wir
haben noch mehr wörter auf dieser langen
liste von interaktionen die man in
deutschland benutzt und stellen euch
gerne noch mehr vor in einem zweiten
teil von diesem video
und wenn ihr lust habt mehr kleine
szenen zu sehen so wie ihr sie auch in
diesem video gesehen habt dann guckt
auch mal bei tik tok vorbei
easy german ist nämlich jetzt ganz
offiziell auch bei tik tok und dort
spielen wir jede woche ganz verschiedene
dialoge und szenen mit deutscher
alltagssprache tschüss und bis nächste
woche war er sich sarina das ist
christies hobby